foreign
[Applause]
EST Innovations from Zurich it removes
all pain
guys like me we have to turn their bows
the morphine and that can lead to
addiction oh that's fast that is
advanced
[Music]
two together
uh Christian reminds you when you won
the Golden Globe for the fighter you
went up to the stage you got your ward
and you mentioned Robert De Niro at the
end of your speech and the music cut out
and the music cut out I never got to
hear what you said about Robert and so
seeing you both together I wanted to
first ask you what did you both first
really meet not just in passing and what
do you appreciate the most when watching
the other I think I was very surprised
to be up there I was very delighted I
was having a lot of fun and I saw Bob's
face in the crowd then I gave a few uh a
very complimentary expletives about uh
just how good I thought and and think he
is you know so anona and real pleasure
and so damn satisfying to get to work
with Bob it's amazing what what do you
appreciate the most when watching um
Robert actor Bob
I'm happy to be putting that in that
position you know he's one of the finest
that there has ever been you know he's a
Bedrock of Cinema uh I was actually
sitting and thinking of the films that
I've loved and watched and I don't watch
that many films and neither does Bob
actually you know David is always
frustrated with me and he said it's the
same with Bob that we're constantly
going oh no we didn't see that we didn't
see that but I've seen this man's films
and they're absolutely phenomenal and uh
uh what an honor to get to a a work with
him and just be sitting there uh next to
him but uh but equally
um uh uh we like rolling our sleeves up
Bob loves the way that David works I
love it too so it was a wonderful
partnership I love that
love that yeah no Christian said it was
uh it's always great to work with David
and for us to work together was for me
uh great I wish we had been able to do
more
um and you know David's a very special
person the special director and you know
whatever he's going to do it's going to
be
special and uh noteworthy remembered uh
and that to me is very very important
it's got It's not just a movie that'll
come and go it'll learn someplace and
film history if you will
deservedly so
yes absolutely is this the first time
you guys really met not just in passing
was working on this on this home or had
you guys know I mean you know a little
bit we had a day together on American
Hustle but you know I uh I reserve and
you know and we we just had a day and I
was kind of sitting silently through
most of that scene so uh this is the
most that we've gotten to do but as Bob
said I hope we get to do more yeah I
hope so too fantastic together Christian
you played some Stellar villains
anti-heroes or the god butcher Batman
American Psycho and your character in
this movie Burr is so Earnest and
wholesome and I was wondering if that's
ironically more challenging to play
um you know I mean I do happen to think
the villains always get attention more
easily than the good guys you know
everyone is always fascinated with a bad
guy uh uh but what I love so much about
Bo is he he he's so very easily through
his experiences in life and his painful
life and just how tough it is and the
injuries that he's received mentally and
physically as well he could have turned
uh uh you know to the other side he
could have become full of hatred and
anger but he refuses that he refuses to
go numb he refuses to be a puppet to
these uh bad people uh Puppet Masters
and he maintains optimism and love and
joy throughout his life and I think he's
incredibly inspiring and he's someone
who I would want to be a friend with
yeah it was fun watching you like in
that earnestness and quirkiness
um Robert I wanted to ask you about a
relationship you've had for a very long
time um with New York City you were born
in Manhattan one of the first films you
were ever in was called three rooms in
Manhattan and a lot of this film takes
place in 1930s New York uh do you enjoy
films more when they take place in the
city is there familiarity there that
makes it feel warm to you well just for
practical reasons I like to shoot in New
York but oh you know but there's always
um
to do a good film that takes place in
New York of course that's that's the
most important
thing uh I would prefer having a
if I'm lucky a really terrific script if
I'm really looking at Great script uh to
be shot in New York yeah
there's just something that feels so
right about seeing
speaking of love I also
hope the things we love is it something
that we choose or is it something that
we need I wanted to know when it comes
to acting Robert do you feel like it's
something you chose or do you think it's
something you need
that's interesting it's a it's a
combination of the of both
um
and whatever else to I mean uh you need
it if it's um
what you want uh
what you need I don't know I'm answering
that question as best I can but it sort
of fits and
need want uh Destiny if you will certain
uh projects say with David
David in this particular case this movie
we would he would talk to me about the
script and this and and that's sort of
part of his process and I you know just
um he I'd listen because I knew that's
how it is even when I'm committed to
something it's just a queen that's his
way of like even
finding things in that moment
um that's my interpretation of it at
least
um so that's all good so it's a thing
where you kind of you know at the end of
the day you're going to wind up there
not quite sure how and when yet but
you're figuring it all out and that's
how it works with him
I love that Christian do you feel like
it's something you chose or something
you need I think that every kid needs
and wants to play dress-up right I mean
you know I I do believe the best actors
are animals and children and I Look to
them you know there's so much
inspiration because they don't give a
damn about the effect or the
consequences they're just in the moment
uh living it so I think everybody does
that I then found myself in a situation
where it became a need because my dad
got ill and I became the breadwinner at
a very young age so I started acting
professionally actually because I needed
to you know and I actually didn't want
to I wanted to rebel against it I was
like I don't want to do this but I knew
that man I had to and then fortunately
enough you know you keep doing it long
enough of course you've got to pay the
bills this is how we make our livings
you know and so there is need there but
you're fortunate enough to keep doing it
long enough that right now absolutely
it's a choice you know right now
at this point things may change in the
future
but at this point I don't need to do it
but I choose to do it because I want to
do it because I love doing it yeah
really quick you both chose to be in
films where you're with this character
The Joker and I was wondering has that
character ever come up in your dreams or
nightmares for either of you
no
I I have to say look uh I I miss Heath
dealy and yeah he'll crop up but but
it's Heath it's Heath not the Joker
that's the rich we find ourselves in a
situation where we're accused of killing
someone which is not true
Ewan Woodman fled the scene the killer
pointed at us we didn't do anything why
would you possibly think that was us
well there's not too many people that
fit the description of the doctor
looking for his eye on the ground with
his black Attorney Columbia Law School
the movie's called Amsterdam and I love
that this
is still on vacation and I wanted to ask
all of you where in the world do you
feel like that and what is your
Amsterdam and we'll start with you Margo
I just had a very funny vacation with
Rami actually so but we won't get into
that
um
please do wait we must know we must know
yeah which one
we've gone on quite a load of vacation
Adventures at this since filming this
movie we're going to talk about this but
go on yeah
the people must know yeah let's not talk
about them
yeah no I'm not going to get into it no
go ahead no no no I'm not telling them
the whole story I'll tell you guys left
all right but for me for me my Amsterdam
uh I had a very similar sort of thing I
moved to London on a whim and my two
best friends
uh Josie and Tom we kind of like this
like oh actually do you know what's so
weird the three of us met in Belgium
where the Harold and Valerie met I met
my two best friends there I ended up
marrying one of them them much like
Harold and Valerie fell in love and um
is still like my best friends and then
this time in London was my my bubble
like my Amsterdam I love that answer
thanks sorry what about you Rob
he'll tell us about the vacations we had
a good summer that was a kind of an
Amsterdam yeah you want to go let's go
we've had two good songs
that was fun you know we didn't get to
have a wrap party because of covert but
the three of us ended up and Chris and
Chris yeah yeah so us and Chris had a
mini rap party we're going off track
here
a lot of feelings then right
okay here we go our Amsterdam uh I went
I
[Music]
uh I I remember finishing a job where I
I guess I was trying to go method and I
didn't know that it uh we had enough it
took a toll on me and I thought for a
second I don't want to act anymore and I
just uh I felt like an expat because I
took a trip to
Argentina and lived in Buenos Aires for
a long time and thought I might never
leave that place and I had uh just an
extraordinary time where uh I felt free
and alive and awake and uh that was my
Amsterdam Amsterdam what was yours today
perhaps Egypt I met Kareem my other
friend I said thanks thanks
um I'm at my other half in Egypt we were
it was quite funny uh it's it all seemed
very romantic I just come from Senegal
he's partly Senegalese it all seemed to
make sense we were making a love story
together we and we're still together now
since we made the film it was called
Luxor
we were just looking out on the Nile
watching things float by including like
a dead cow
I said to him where'd you live and he
said Larchmont
and that kind of bursts the bubble right
you know it's a place in L.A
I want to sound ignorant but I'm just
like just back to the studio yeah just
about when we shot the film yeah so I'm
saying like that he lives just where we
shot the film about three minutes from
my house you know so it seems like
perhaps less
um adventurous than at first but but
Egypt will for its timelessness and it's
um
and it's it's just it's it's like
impenetrable magic so it'll always be
a place where I'm lost
in a way I feel most comfortable
I can't I can't top that but I recently
I did about six months in uh Thailand
Chiang Mai uh I was in Bangkok and I I
pride myself of being very respectful
and and humble but you can't out respect
the humble these people uh it was an
incredible exhibition of consistent
humility and graciousness and and really
a passion for life that I've never seen
I really truly understood peace working
there and that that really that that
whole process changed my life I'll get
into it closer to the release but uh
that that trip really changed my life
changed my particular I was talking to
this 85 year old elephant and just this
elephant just seemed to understand my
all my problems it was like my therapist
when I just saw this elephant Nature
Park and uh it's the people and and the
curry fantastic yeah I feel like my time
in Thailand was very different
[Laughter]
no no
no no I'm sorry what was beautiful to
hear all those answers because it really
is cool how um different places in the
world can make you guys all feel those
different things
yeah what's your answer I am
some of that thanks
um I think for me after
afronia
um I was volunteering in the Masai Mara
last December and elephants are so
emotional and amazing right like the
Earth untouched I was like why do I work
in a room on a computer but anyways
um John David I wanted to ask you before
I have to wrap up real quick I know you
have this incredible scene in this film
with Christian Bale uh where you're
singing and he was in Newsies and you're
with Taylor Swift who's Taylor Swift
um what was shooting that scene like I
know your mother was on Broadway and how
do you feel you stacked up uh I hope I
didn't let let the family down you know
because she can't sing for real my
sister could sing and she's a Pianist so
no it was I felt comfortable like I've
been saying it all day like the there
were no Eagles on this set and Taylor
Swift is just she was so cool and and
just acquiescent to the process and just
was able to flow and gave me confidence
because she was so nice and
accommodating so you know I can there
was no wrong choices even if there was
wrong notes and tones
[Laughter]
[Music]
it's a dangerous times you be careful
I'm about to do something that could
cost me my life
the cuckoo is in the nest and the cuckoo
is about to be trapped
hello Mike and Michael hi hi how many
times did someone refer to one of you on
set and the other thought they were
talking about
uh well they they kept us separated so
that that wouldn't happen he'd be on one
side of the room and I'd be on the other
because you can imagine how horrific
that would be yeah yes the nightmare
scenario that is you know doomsday
scenario yeah really I would refer to it
as a dream like scenario
on screen made me LOL so oh
yeah I never thought in my wildest
dreams if you had told me like 20 years
ago you're gonna get to be like in a duo
with Mike Myers I would have just
guffawed I didn't even think that would
be remotely possible it's like just the
ultimate international Man of Mystery
yeah exactly exactly I love it you guys
are both clearly so funny together in
this movie and it must be nice to have a
great script and be able to elevate it
were the both of you riffing at all
because it feels that way when you're
watching it you know was any of it
improvised oh yeah we had some uh we had
a hall pass there and yeah explore yeah
definitely
but um yeah David encourages it
because I think like David he writes the
script and he's super super serious
about it and then at the last minute
he's like you know what forget that
let's see what else is going on well
it's scenarios you can't improvise some
things you can't improvise a set you
can't improvise a special effect you
know you can't improvise 12 swans flying
you know so a lot of stuff is in the
script how you how it's actually phrased
he's always if it fits in your mouth
better and if it seems to he's looking
for organic he sort of wants to almost
it'd be a staged documentary as kind of
his feel did you guys end up shooting
I never saw The Cutting Room floor
I don't know what ended up there I hope
they sweep yeah
you know it could be
bugs or something uh I don't know I I
don't think there's I to be frank I
haven't seen the movie yet so I haven't
I I never remember I I get uh cutting
Asia yeah I I you know what I mean I
also get virginitis I never remember you
know because I write a lot of my own
stuff so I right
I was good do you remember that part and
my wife Kelly goes that wasn't in the
movie didn't make the Final Cut
okay it's
already in the film and the scenario
because to me I don't know why but bird
watching is just comedic like even the
words bird watching is funny to me I
don't know why I can't pinpoint it if
this film was a bird what bird do you
think it would be my an American Eagle
there you go why
because
uh in the end democracy
triumphs
they were an endangered species
but uh the only reason the American
Eagle
is back is because it meant something to
people and it needed to be protected so
I think it is the American Eagle
democracy is a very fragile experiment
and in the world
of History democracy is like right there
and this is present time you know what I
mean
and uh it's a very thin membrane
democracy
and it uh it needs to be protected you
know like a Faberge egg
that was such a beautiful well thought
out answer I love that
um Michael Shannon what was it like uh
working with Robert De Niro actually for
the both of you both start with you
Michael
well I'm one I was about the bird
question oh I'm sorry what bird
well I would say it's it's an American
Eagle but it's directed by a hummingbird
yes yes because that's the energy of
David yeah it's like and like poking the
getting the the stuff out of the flower
and yeah anyway that's my answer that
question uh working with De Niro was uh
I I mean I I I was in a State of Shock
really I mean the guy is uh
one of my all-time uh Heroes of of
acting I remember you know seeing all
his films
uh back when I was a teenager you know a
taxi driver and Raging Bull and
king of comedy is actually one of my
favorite favorite movies
um so yeah to be there in front of him
was uh pretty extraordinary he's also
really nice he gave he gave us all uh an
orchid I worked in my dressing room one
day and there was an orchid on the
counter and a little car that said you
know handwritten yeah handwritten card
welcome to the show looking forward to
working with you Robert De Niro
so I threw that out no I'm just kidding
I still have it yeah
yeah Mike you know you've done some
incredible
over the course of your career I was
actually wondering do you have a Robert
De Niro impersonation uh silent
this is it
that's it and that's it it's not good
and we'll obviously cut that out yeah
don't we don't turn this into another
Tom Hiddleston on Graham Norton that was
terrible by the way thank you
no I look like a muppet forget it it
looked like I it could have been that or
it was the Muppet version of Robert yes
that's when Robert De Niro was I only do
lots of Impressions yeah yeah